ich habe gesagt wir streben eine
europäische lösung an es hat sich kein
mitgliedsland bisher bereit erklärt und
dann müssen sie in der politik
entscheiden ob sie weiter treiben lassen
oder zu handeln und wir haben eine
personengruppe identifiziert wo man sehr
verantwortlich sagen kann die holen wir
nach deutschland das sind anerkannte
asylbewerber
das verfahren ist durchlaufen die können
sofort können sie in deutschland sind
das wird allerdings in vielen stufen
erfolgen hier integriert werden und wir
sollten bei der ganzen diskussion nicht
vergessen dass die griechen vor einigen
monaten die europäische außengrenze
geschützt haben
wenn sie sich zurück erinnern dass die
türken ja die flüchtlinge in großem maße
über diese grenze nach europa und damit
auch zu uns schleusen wollten
und wenn die griechen das nicht
verhindert hätten hätten wir ganz andere
flüchtlingsströme nach europa bekommen
das muss man auch ein bisschen mit
bedenken aber die stärke hierzulande ist
nicht eine gute erinnerung wir haben
nach wie vor die situation zu diesem
thema in deutschland dass die meinungen
sehr heterogen sind es gibt hier keine
eindeutige meinung in der gesellschaft
sie haben es beschrieben die einen
warnen die anderen fordern
und in einer solchen situation sind sie
immer gut beraten wenn sie politik mit
augenmaß machen nicht mit extremen
positionen
das war sowieso nie weil meine neigung
sondern mit augenmaß mit sauberen
argumenten mit geduld sie können sich
vorstellen was da alles übers wochenende
behauptet wurde über mich ist alles käse
sie müssen sich von den fakten
orientieren und dann eine
verantwortliche entscheidung treffen und
ich bin sehr froh gewesen am montagabend
dass wir uns dann in einem vier augen
gespräch bei der kanzlerin in sehr sehr
kurzer zeit verständigten auf eine
ausbalancierte lösung
die hilfe vor ort und eine
personengruppe nach deutschland zu holen
von der größenordnung 1500 die sauber
abgrenzbar ist die anerkannte ist die
schutzbedürftig ist weil die verfahren
schon durchgeführt wurden
genauso wie die kinder die wir geholt
haben die 243 kranken kinder mit ihren
angehörigen
das ist verantwortliche politik und ich
bin froh darüber
da kann man ja helfen vor ort wir haben
organisiert das deutsche rote kreuz des
thw und die sind mit mehreren konvois
nach griechenland unterwegs die
kanzlerin hat mit nicht so zart dass es
gesprochen dass das auch abgestimmt ist
zwischen der griechischen regierung und
uns als es läuft perfekt also nochmals
der opposition sagen wir haben jetzt
europaweit millionen von flüchtlingen
der ganze balkan ist von flüchtlingen
malta zypern sizilien italien spanien
und so ist der deutschen öffentlichkeit
mal erklären dass deutschland ein
aufenthaltsort ist für all diese
flüchtlingen wir müssen schon mit
augenmaß und verantwortlichkeit das
ganze machen
das zeigt eigentlich die miserable lage
bei der migrationspolitik in europa wir
werden vor einer herkules aufgabe stehen
wenn wir ab der nächsten woche versuchen
die künftige europäische asylpolitik zu
definieren und der bestand und die
handlungsfähigkeit europas hängt auch
mit dieser frage zusammen ob diese
europäische union als werteordnung in
der lage ist ein asylsystem für die
zukunft zu zimmern
das für viele jahre hinaus die antwort
ist auch diese probleme denn das
migrations thema wird uns viele jahre
erhalten bleiben
mich hat niemand getränken des treffens
war klar wenn ich überzeugt bin dass
etwas nicht geht dann mache ich es auch
nicht und wenn ich überzeugt bin dass
karmann verantworten und ruhig
so ist meine politik immer schon gewesen
oder nutzt nichts wenn dann einer kommt
und sagt wir wollen aber während das
doppelte das hat schlimmer nicht so dass
eine reine exekutive maßnahme und kein
gesetzgeber den fotos und setzt so
verständigt haben wenn die spd ihnen das
bisher anders interpretiert das ist ihre
aufgabe als journalist das auszuleuchten